the white house correspondents dinner
one of the capital's biggest social
events returned on saturday for the
first time in three years the event went
on despite concerns about covid as
o'keefe shows us high profile
celebrities joined journalists and
government figures including president
biden
i'm really excited to be here tonight
with the only group of americans with a
lower approval rating than i have
armed with a few one-liners president
biden was the first commander-in-chief
to headline the white house
correspondents dinner since 2016.
this is the first time
president attended this dinner in six
years
it's understandable
we had a horrible plague
followed by two years of covet
canceled for two years by the pandemics
this year's dinner drew more than 2 000
journalists politicians and yes a few
celebrities who had to be vaccinated and
test negative for coving but that didn't
stop the jokes it is my great honor to
be speaking tonight at the nation's most
distinguished super spreader events
the daily shows trevor noah dished out
the biggest laughs mostly at the
president's expense ever since you've
come into office things are really
looking up you know gas is up rent is up
food is up
everything
cbs news radio's steven portnoy led the
evening as president of the
correspondents association our democracy
depends on journalists shining light and
truth upon darkness and lies
and bringing accountability to officials
at every level of our government the
president and noah agree despite the
pandemic laughter and partying calling
out those in position of power is a
distinctly american trait trevor the
really good news is
now you get to roast the present united
states and unlike in moscow you won't go
to jail
i stood here tonight and i made fun of
the president of the united states and
i'm going to be fine
i'm going to be fine right
like like do you really understand what
a blessing is
the dinner is a lot of fun but it's also
for a good cause they handed out more
than 130 000
to 31 students at 15 universities tony
was great to see you and everybody else
well you know ed we were at the very
best table i know i was because you were
there as well uh yeah you guys had a
cool kid's table i'm so glad you
mentioned steve portnoy of cbs because
he did a terrific job emceeing the night
and he's been working on it for over a
year so well done special mommy hug to
steve he did a great job also great job
trevor noah yeah yeah because it is so
hard to thread that new needle to take a
little jab a little bruise a little
punch but he wasn't mean that's the
thing he wasn't mean and he was actually
very very funny but what he's done
throughout his career um even dating
back to his stand up is he's layered the
truth yeah between the funny and a lot
of truth is said and just you can
appreciate walking away after him
talking to the world and really
understanding where we are as a country
and what we can be thankful for
absolutely as it was cracking up and
some of the jokes directed at him yeah
he was ed o'keefe thank you again nate
same time next year i'm there i'm there
all right i'm there okay got a spot at
my table for you